did you know that Rhino potentially has
a long-lost relative who was a member of
the Scouts in episode 1 we were briefly
introduced to a character called Moses
and thanks to the manga we know that his
full name was Moses Braun as we know
Brawn is Reiner's family name and what's
interesting is that not only do they
look very similar but in the final
season Ryan's mother said those who left
us and fled to the island should be
punished this refers to the fact that a
hundred years ago many LDN families were
divided with some choosing to go to the
island While others stayed in Mali it's
possible that Moses was one of the
bronze who left to go to eldia and if
that's the case it would mean they are
blood relatives